thing that could happen is that um I
mean we've all made a cost application
through
um or been involved in cost applications
for withdrawn appeals and you don't get
an answer quickly
um and by quickly I mean I put one in
May and I still haven't heard and I
doubt uh so you're going to take that
long to determine
so we're going to have cost applications
that are completely different
times I wonder if there's is there no
mechanism to our pins to actually is
that the same person whether it's you or
the costume dealing with well in fact
the coffee
I just suppose the costume could do with
the substantive
aspect because it's going to be relevant
to your decision is there no discretion
for you to determine the whole thing
well
so this is where it gets it gets
complicated let's just think about this
as fact the substantive
um
in relation to
in relation to appeal a
my assumption is
that you would be making a claim for
cost in relation to all the costs
relating to a pla yeah
it doesn't matter where you call it
substantive procedural or whatever yeah
but that obviously just relates to
ground d
yeah
you can still make
an application for a substantive
rewarding relation to ground B some
ground B appeal B yeah which I would
deal with
and the only difference is that
um
part of your
part of your claim would be that
[Music]
um
an inquiry was necessitated by appeal a
yeah because we would have to put in
that application that um
the inquiry you know the the regressive
as they are
um
you know why why no priests were
produced why we came here in September
when bullets wasn't quite sat and you
know we didn't need to
um
that relates to both plane and and and
plb so we just put in both applications
and
obviously the amount of course has
nothing to do with me no no no no no
but the
um
got concerns about about the way the
application was made but you're seeing
that you're seeking substantive Award of
costs in relation to
okay well appeal uh D
um and and and on a procedural basis and
also on on ground sorry appeal B
grounds and appeals get mixed up here
yeah it'll be
um you're saying you're saying that the
um ground a case had no reason or
prospects of success yeah I mean if um I
need to take instructions but it may the
answer may be that if um they have to be
dealt with by two different
uh people
um what may make sense is that we start
again
do it all in paper and send
everybody all the information so
everyone knows what everyone else is
doing
um but it just seems um right you asked
you asked me whether there's any scope
or yeah
the the
um
I mean you know you'd like to do
another yeah
[Music]
the difficulty is that
like I said I have to remind myself of
this situation and that I know there
have been numerous occasions when
inspectors have merrily dealt with cots
applications for withdrawn pills because
they didn't aware that they weren't
supposed you know yeah the the the
um
the problem with that is what standing
does that decision actually have but
there is a middle ground but it's a
little bit complicated the middle ground
is that or in relation to
um appeal a I effectively do like a
report
for the Secretary of State with a
recommendation on costs and the
Secretary of State
through the cost decision team
effectively formally makes the decision
on it on you know having regard to my
recommendation it's just a bit fiddly
because I did be making a decision on
part of it and a recommendation on on
the other but I'm just trying to think
through what
what the Practical consequences are
um of doing it either either way I
suppose the other way I do is we simply
um
start again I think we'd have to start
to get into it do it on paper
um
and then internally
pins just work out what they want to do
with it
yeah right I'm not entirely in favor of
that for the reasons I'll come on to a
moment because I would still be
that the chances are the cost decision
team would say to me you deal with that
part of it because you did the inquiry
as far as you know so they wouldn't want
to be involved in that okay withdrawn
appeals are relatively straightforward
starting point is you know withdrawal of
appeal is one of those things that will
you you can rebut this but the starting
point is that it may result you know
yeah would institutions be that they are
they're asked to only deal with the
actual late withdrawal of the appeals so
so what we would argue essentially is
that well the appeal should have been
withdrawn earlier
um and and they'll say no we there's a
very good reason why we would do it at a
minute it's 10.
um
and then and then you um
and then you deal with everything else
including
the um failure activities proofs and
everything
otherwise we're not going to know who to
put the application to
yeah but
[Music]
um
let me explain why I'm not because this
links into what was being said further
about whether whether applications
should be made and responded to in
writing or not
I can tell I mean the
um the planning practice guidance
um
indicates that um
it's normal to hear applications at the
the inquiry itself it
does say that
um obviously the the
respondent should have an opportunity to
respond if necessary in writing and I
said to you earlier I'd make a decision
about whether I thought it was necessary
for you to have that time
um
the cat the planning inspector's own
practice is to deal with them at the at
the hearing or inquiry saving
um I think expression it uses is very
exceptional circumstances
now one of the reasons for that all
right this is my take on it because the
guidance doesn't actually say something
but one of the reasons for that is
when you're making applications for
costs in relation to substantive matters
what you will often see in a written
cost application is things which should
have been said about the merits of the
appeal yeah as part of the appeal itself
it gets really difficult because people
use it as an opportunity to make
arguments they should have made before
that actually relate to the substance of
the appeal and that's one of the reasons
for not doing it in that way so in that
case so what we could do is to deal with
it subject to my little friend's
objection to deal with it all already
tomorrow and then you Hive off the
different bits to the relevant so you
deal with what you can deal with and
then you ask Pennsylvania well as I say
that's that's one milligram idea but
then pins are going to be some consumers
in eight months time when they get
around to dealing and they're going to
have your notes from what was said and
that's gonna be quite hard for them to
do it isn't it
I mean I'm sure you'll know it's
excellent but but it's um well um as I
said the way the way it would the way it
would work is
um I would be making a decision on
appeal B and
a recommendation
on
appeal a and you're saying
time yeah
normally we don't issue
but normally we issue cost decisions at
the same time as the the appeal decision
so we don't want the appealers to be
delayed
sorry I'm this is a little bit being
confused but I it just wants to start
thinking thinking through the
implications it's not a straightforward
I think that's probably the simplest
from our Point well I think from
everyone's point of view
that is a little bit more work before
unless I've been doing all the talk you
know
I understand with interest I mean
I hesitate to raise procedural
experiences again it simply isn't my
experience the last I've gone back over
the last five plus applications I go
Awards I've obviously not made that that
often but over the last 12 months five
cost applications all have been dealt
with in writing and they've been dealt
with with a seven day response appeal
but had sorry to interrupt but has that
been because there isn't necessarily
time to deal with it at that query it's
been dealt with on a fairness and
proportionality basis uh but that's my
experience that's just my experience and
I can't see why
these matters can't be dealt with enough
foreign
I can't see why these matters can't be
dealt with in writing so that both
elements are put in writing I'm given
the opportunity to respond you deal with
your pins deals with the other parts
well so I've given my viewers to why
why I prefer them not to be just just in
writing as I say and and put the other
thing I'd say
made a joke about boasting about my 20
years of experiences of planning is
better but I'd also before that I had
experience as a as a as an advocate
doing planning inquiries so I've had to
make and respond to planning cost
applications on I know this was in the
old days but uh planning
um cost applications on the hoof as they
both making the man responding to them
so
you know so I've repeat every
everybody's got a different experience
and I suppose there are there are
perhaps not only inspectors to deal with
things on a different basis but they're
not necessarily doing it in a way that
pins is telling them they should deal
with it
yeah I mean obviously the variations all
I can do is give you that depending
right here I can't see what personally I
can't it's a matter for you uh and you
know you clearly got quite strong using
positioning it's absolutely fine but I
can't see why it shouldn't be set out in
writing properly in the former in
response and you just Hive off the bits
you need to I can't see the Prejudice
myself
yeah well apart from the you know the
the stages in the process there's a
written application you get to respond
the council get the final the final word
and as I say there's a there's a danger
that matches get raised in the
representation on costs which are
they just have to be ignored I mean
they're not supposed to be there and
that would be inappropriate to do so uh
I don't know that's a reason not to do
it
anyway
[Music]
foreign
because a lot comes down to just What
What In addition what you're going to
say in addition to what you've already
put in writing yeah
okay
all right
so we're at I mean I don't get typical
just don't be surprised if I make an
application Tomorrow based on exception
I won't be surprised
exactly exactly so you know I mean it
seems sensible just to deal with it all
now but but I think that's where it will
be well as I said not the reason I'm not
dealing with now is because if if if if
Mr me fed
makes a couple of very brief comments in
addition to what he's already put in
writing then I don't see why you should
need a lot of time to actually respond
to that so it's particularly since as
far as the withdrawal is concerned you
must have anticipated
an application for costs
and unless Mr lever comes up with a
ground for that application which you
couldn't have anticipated then you know
you've already had time
my concern I mean with Bruce actually
spent about 45 minutes talking about
this
um
time before
but the cost application wasn't clear to
me and that's we've had some debate all
I want to understand is the final
resting position of the council and then
you know and have a fair and
proportionate way to respond if that's
going to be just a little bit extra
that's fine but they you know my I don't
know if you read my response uh
it was a detailed look at the way that
applications cast and it seems on any
basis that is going to be really cast
we'll see
right so we're on and as far as the
agenda is concerned
um two things for some reason I put
conditions at seven I think that makes
sense to deal with that right at right
at the end so I'll relegate that to the
end of the discussion and then there was
also ground G which isn't on the agenda
and I say that the outset to Mr leaflet
that I give him an opportunity to
comment on that aspect after opening
submissions and then I forgot to do that
so
another Point that's his site visit so I
have spoken to Oh Mr Telford spoke to
the
um owner and unfortunately he is away
tomorrow
and their parents as an appointment was
at health
it's an appointment that's been booked
for six months anyways Mr Telford can't
be there because well what was about
because we get that no no we get that
sorry Mr Telephone can't can't be here
tomorrow right uh because he his wife's
got a
question I will go however the property
is going to be over and I think Tyler
Harris who is the girl who lives or the
lady who lives in the uh lived in the
lodge she will be able to open the gate
so all I was going to say was that we're
not going to and I think the um garage
building will be open as well
um but we're not going to have Mr Talbot
and it's not going to be the landowner
it will just be me which is slightly
unusual precise that will to facilitate
tonight okay it's also unfortunate
because at the time I was expecting
you'd have an opportunity to finalize
your closing well some of the time being
able to finance closing submissions but
so this has been in the diary for months
and there's been a constant feature of
this Penance not here as Witnesses
aren't here things are pulled out Mr
telford's not here it's
you've got my views on and I think the
council's behavior easily and all I'm
saying is that it will be me tomorrow
there won't be anybody else around going
out and it'll be me but there'll be
access to the garage but does that cause
Unity
problems as long as you can see what you
um need to see I mean as as uh before my
little friends have got strong crisis of
off the couch with this the council is
extremely sympathetic to Mr selfie's
wife in fact many of us would have had
personal experience of of that sort of
issue
um but the fact is the inquiry was
booked for two days
um Mr Telford knew that if he had a
problem with the secondary he could have
raised it weeks ago
not standing in the way with Cyprus and
I'm just telling you he was going to be
all right okay
okay well if you're happy with Mr hardly
being there it doesn't really it doesn't
really matter so okay sorry I I
almost got a preemption
very bad very bad trait to an inspector
that is but there we go
right so um
that takes us to item six on the agenda
but we really we've we've talked about
other considerations in terms of the
fallback
uh position so the question
for the appendix release that are there
any other considerations that you you
think I should be taking into account to
weigh against the harm by reason of
inappropriativeness and any other harm
that I find
it is in the written proofs as well
we're picking up highlights here so the
council will rely on all of his written
evidence as well yeah
um I don't know if this all he wants to
highlight anything in addition
and and and and just also if you're
honest as well some of these points are
sort of buried in the um ground C uh
material so the calculations of heights
the the different paragraph numbers
relevant to
um the garage the new garage and the
unfinished building they fall far
different
um high terrorists that's that's that's
within I think the ground c section of
of Mr um because that was the um PD
because it was ground C was the PD point
so so it says in the various um
it will be necessary
um to to to to look at those
um
sections
and I can try and draw some of that out
in the um
in in the closing submissions over are
you overnight
um
it's it's the appeal's taking an unusual
course
so then if we go on to
I mean
I
you you I don't mean I could I'm not
putting words into your mouth when I say
you you obviously don't think that harm
is clearly outweighed you think it is
it's not really much more to say on that
that score is there is it's an
unfinished building in the Greenbelt in
a particularly sensitive landscape
location so we've made it clear that um
uh the ground is numerous at all
I think in summary it's an inappropriate
development which harms openness spatial
to a specialist visual extent
and there's no very special
circumstances
um so there's also a point about Mr
Telford
um referred to an appeal decision in is
um I think he called it his witness
statement essentially is
um supplementary or I think there
already was a supplementary proof but
the latest one that posed September
proof
um
um he didn't name the appeal decision we
did our best to find it uh he's done his
best to find it nobody can finally
appeal decision to which he refers
there's a there's a news story that that
refers to it
um but um we would say very little ways
indeed can be given to an appeal
decision that no one can find
unless of course you pull the rabbit out
the hat so well I'm not doing anything
I'm not digging around things
with respect it's a bit late to um
you know if we don't have a chance to
comment on what season has not been
forced to put in yeah
if I find it might be helpful obviously
if inspector doesn't want to see if that
that's fair enough
that we're going to make an application
um in relation to what what the council
has said if I might respond I think it
exposes to uh mistakes firstly
um this isn't just an unfinished
building and that's what my learning
friends said there is of course one
finished building that's the garage uh
you have to deal with both of these uh
appeals separately and the carriage we
say merits consideration on its own you
may come to a view that that actually is
more acceptable
causes less harm and therefore the BSC
case in relation to that is different so
they have a bad pin day A bad pen day
I've had one of those two two of mine
have packed up today so it's probably
catching in the in the building
so there are two
two separate buildings clearly it isn't
just a case when I'm finished building
uh you've got one and I think you you
may form a view that there are
differences between the two and that
harm uh caused by the garage is rather
lesser and in relation to a grander you
may say well actually proportionality
and so on means that the garage is in is
cast in a better light than the than the
other building so that's the first point
the second I think is a common mistake
that Mr Holly makes which is that you
know he was trying to or referring to
they're not being very special
circumstances is it as if that is the
input very special circumstances of
course of the output and we know that
from paragraph 148 that that is the
state of being the state of uh of
circumstances which exist if
the harm caused by definition of harm in
any other harm is clearly outweighed so
we're not looking for a list of very
specials the thing is I'm painfully
aware of this because the the one the
one time my one of my decisions has ever
been such good stupid to say this ever
been quashed
back in about 2008 was on this very
point but it was because
um my decision was made before the which
court of appeal decision in which apron
came out so up until that point we all
thought that the words very special
circumstances very special meant
something
um I still think the decision was wrong
because you don't need the words very
special if all you say is the other
circumstances clearly that went out but
I understand that is yes so that's the
analytical point exactly that's the
point but what that does is then get
back into I don't want to labor you know
again you've got strong views uh in
relations to um the analysis in
paragraph 148.
the equation only works or can work if
you know how much harm there is and the
harm it goes back to uh having that the
ball of harm to which you apply the
substantial way and that's going to vary
and that will determine the consequence
of that is that the The Wider benefits
that are required to clearly outweigh
may be lesser or greater no yes clearly
if you've got a smaller ball of arm to
which you apply the constant to
substantial weight you might need a few
of these there's no dispute about that
it's it's just that the was that however
small the ball of harm is it will still
be it will still carry substantial
weight
absolutely yeah then we're absolutely in
accord and you may take the view so just
following on from that the the garage
actually causes a smaller ball you know
the ball of harm in relation to gauge is
smaller than in relation to the uh to
the to the other building I'm just
slightly confused by that because
um in some respects Mr Telephone was
suggesting it might be the other way
round because the because the garage
wasn't as well related to the dwellings
I'm just saying that one or the other
I'm saying one or the other what the
point I'm making is that you can't lump
them together they both got their
um differences and you have to fall
maybe that starts to put that's the
point I'm making
okay thank you
foreign
seven at the moment and go on to
eight
um
now obviously the enforcement notice
itself
says that its purpose is to remedy
the breach of planning control
and just just check with your parents
agree that having regards to the the
requirements of the notice
thank you
that was a quick one nine so the the
allegation says the breach is the
construction of the two buildings
so can I just ask the council so why
then is the removal of the hard standing
uh necessary to remedy that
specified breach
because the hard standing appears to be
part and parcel of the building is
included within the building operations
themselves
certainly the installation of any
underground infrastructure to serve that
building
um is part of the building
and within the steps of the notices
appropriate to require
all those Works to be reversed
any response to that
so the notice refers to the building and
the hardest standing is not part of the
building at all the outstanding unless
they're talking about the hardstanding
being the hard stunning on which the
building is erected uh than the hard
standing was not formed part of the
building
um the other the notice you for the
school and authorized buildings
uh if they had wanted to outstanding
they would have and they'd felt it
outstanding required consent and the
notice should have been more specific
uh and referred to all the issues that
they want removed not just the
unauthorized building itself
so we would argue in fact that it's uh
it's excessive what that does of course
is raise somac travel I'm sure you're
aware so much travel against London 1987
and our view is that that doesn't fall
foul of the principle about facilitation
it's a separate part yeah I mean it's so
much trouble and Murphy they're about
changes of use and operational
development which facilitates that
rather than operational development
associated with other operational
developments I don't think it applies
anyway yeah
you know who would agree and there's
more recent Authority on that as well
the um
what is that motivation I thought you
know I was just trying to think it's
it's um well I remember it's that sex
club in in the country style do you
remember you know the case of the really
famous
do you know what does Kestrel Hydro yes
that was my appeal
well it was half in the terrible
decision but my case
wraps all those points together yes so
that's that's the authority so when you
said more reason I was thinking because
that was quite a long time ago now
something yeah it was but it's more
recent than um so much trouble yes
um the um I think I know Keith Lynn Blum
said to one of his colleaguesian
Chambers a case which was interesting on
its facts
[Laughter]
it's uh yeah every time someone
suggested planning law is a bit boring
but uh the um I'd be dining out on that
one
the um uh I was actually going to say
something important which I thought was
important but oh and so you do of course
have the uh Power to vary the
enforcement notice
um yes and this is Prejudice to the
other side and and see it's been
abundantly clear
um well everyone's been talking about so
I can't see if you were to vote and it's
include the hard standing there'd be any
Prejudice whatsoever to the occurred
boxes
well I need to get your response to that
either Mr Telford or Mr hardy or
sorry Mr yes Mr hardy Prejudice uh and
the the basis on which this uh the the
character is very keen to say it's been
running a long time absolutely uh that's
the notice that's what's been responded
to so for Council now wants to say
actually that's uh that's not it's not
correctly fought then relying on your
um uh your discretion to a man we would
oppose that
has responded to it in his evidence he
has considered the hard standing
um so it's it's difficult to see well
it's just to say that it's not part of
the evidence is it's not part of the
same uh not part of the same development
what you're now seeking to do is change
that and we say that is prejudicial so
um
uh it's the witness statement of Mr
tarford in this paragraph 4.29
at 4 30
um
Roman one removal of the hard standing
as did it's considered unreasonable to
require the removal of heart standings
the pennant will use the land
as car parking or garden and the removal
of the hard standing X retention will
have no impact on the openness of the
Greenback so it wasn't I mean I've
raised this point but it wasn't the the
case that's been put hasn't been put on
the basis that um that it was not part
of the alleged breach yeah
so I just don't on that basis
Mr hardy if
at the moment
um
what the appellant is aware of is that
there's a notice which apart from
requiring the demolition of buildings
requires the removal of the hard
standing
and he's put the case on the basis that
will actually
I can use it
you know relation to
um as car parking or garden Etc
um if if in addition
it said that
the notice should be corrected so the
allegations specifically refers to
that hard standing in what way is
he worse off
or in what way would have that would
that have changed the basis on which the
appeal was made
no can I can we just be clear yes which
hard standing is actually being special
is there anything that falls apart and
parcel of the building
and the notice relates to building
operations so if you look at figure 18
on uh paragraph two paragraph 10.5 of
Mr
holidays
give us the
foreign
but it is 10.5 yeah
yeah
the photograph shows no matter how uh
for a start but uh it's not the hard
standing that's been talked about it
it's actually people talking about
different hard standings if that's the
is that your point
it's not it's not the hard study on
which the building is it's the other
half step one which Vehicles apart I
think that's that's what Mr Hall has
just said it's our stunning is where the
vehicles can park now what is meant by
the notice is anything that's included
within the building
part and parcel of the building
when you say within the building you
know that was the footprint of the
building the footprint of the building
yeah the notice the notice refers to the
buildings oh all right does that it
doesn't allege the construction of hard
standards okay so all right so in that
case I think it does need
correcting but in a way which actually
assists absolutely absolutely yeah in
fact I'm not sure whether it's necessary
to
it's unusual to refer to hard standing
under a building I mean it doesn't
really make a lot of sense
yeah it may well have been better
or any yeah
it's it's a firm base isn't it on which
a building okay all right with it we
were clearly across purposes but let's
just have a look at the um
notice B isn't
foreign
have to remove the building you've got
to remove the foundations and so on and
remove all that arising from from that
demolition so
um
this is including in final range
connections
um
is there a
is there an alternative wording that you
would suggest
um
yeah well quite possibly I'd be happy to
have a look at it but I just need to
have a little bit of time to think about
it anyway what's clear
what's clear with the purposes of the
notice is that they are there to Target
the buildings and anything that is
integral to the construction of those
buildings all right I was just assuming
you were saying that all the heart that
hard stand you can see in that
photograph was was part and parcel of
the building which was causing me a
little bit I would probably have
referred to that separately within the
within the alleged breach and preferably
yeah
you're not standing anything on it apart
from the building but yeah
yeah
okay
leave that to your Discretions so if it
said
um
if it said
demolish the unauthorized buildings
including the slab foundations found
fell drainage connections Etc
that's underneath this as well but um we
don't really know what's
up
[Laughter]
yeah it's simply a
well I hated
no no it wasn't I I wasn't particularly
there it's just it
was more that the wording captures
everything under that um building we
don't we don't actually know what's
there we might it doesn't need to be
anything more than building probably it
probably doesn't
um but there's a reference to the for
buried tanks where are these buried
tanks
yeah that is just based on an assumption
of what may well be underneath that
building with with the information that
was available to us at that time we
mainly the requirement
I think it's just parts and parts of the
building so because because a buried
tank might to me it meant like a septic
tank or something you know which
wouldn't be under the building itself
um
oh
um
I've got a feeling this was mentioned on
6th of September but I've gone
everybody
um so the bottom line is would the
council have any problem with me simply
saying with if with me correcting the
notice to Simply refer to demolition of
the building
um to buildings that's usually what
notice is do and then you remove all the
materials arising from that
that demolition
and don't normally detail everything
that might be under that building itself
like you say it's part and parcel of the
building anyway
okay I thought you were suggesting this
white larger area of outstanding was
part and possible
the building right okay
um
foreign
um risk of laboring point is it says any
hard selling found drainage connections
I know buried tanks what you sometimes
get with these things is people leave
things under the ground in the hope that
at some point they're going to get a
planning permission
um
and I think that eventuality needs to
needs to be captured
well if they do get that information
yeah that's fine but otherwise I don't
I know but you end up I mean this was in
um
um
to the Sam Smith case you get some stuff
underground and everyone says well it
doesn't matter because it's the green
but you can't you know you can't see it
but it does matter if
you have a holiday underground stuff in
Greenbelt I think that's that's the
point
so I've never used 52 years in planning
I've never used the fact that there's a
tank underground to justify uh Planet
concept for a building gosh I'll try it
out
debris around the person that you know
everybody's going to go everything
everything that we need to go to I think
like that I think that's the point as
well I think that but that's you know as
I said that's the usual yeah
um if there's bits left there then you
would say well you're not properly
demolished the building or removed yeah
materials arising from that that's the
whole you can go out with his metal
detection
I just it's just I'm thinking well if if
I've not done this before in any other
appeals maybe me and all the other
inspectors have been wrong another
planning offices have been wrong by not
not referring to it but I don't think
it's I'm not aware of it ever having
caused no a problem
um
so can I just mention on the photograph
while we've got the photo yeah in front
the point I was making earlier about
parking in that area
the sahadstas the gravel area there
which you would now excluded from the
terms of the notice and you can see the
size of the uh that's the horse box
uh that's there uh the motorhome uh is
slightly bigger
um
that's the area where vehicles that
aren't used on a daily basis will be
parked
now the point the thing about this is
that
Mike the my my question was on the
assumption that you meant the notice to
catch the hard standing so on your
understanding of things that would have
gone but as I said that's not what you
intended anyway so you approached this
on the basis that the notice isn't
requiring a removal of that so unless
other enforcement action can and is
taken that hard standing will remain and
so obviously that is a factor in terms
of you know the fallback position the
like you know the like that would have
used for other things and so on and the
fact that there is there is an impact on
openness in any event from the existence
of the heart standing appreciate it's
different from from the building but I
appreciate their ReSound impact on yeah
vehicles
yeah yes I mean
look at the point the notice was issued
there are a lot of this hard standing is
covered in building materials and
construction materials
certainly wasn't being used before the
garage went up for any parking
and I don't I mean I haven't looked into
detail when it was there so I'm not I'm
not saying the council can't take action
in relation to it that's a matter for
you to consider but as far as this
well I suppose I suppose I do need to to
know something about that in terms of
how what what
um what account I take of the hard
standing in terms of its impact on on
openness if if it can if the council are
going to take enforcement action to
remove that separately yeah then that's
that's something I suppose I need to be
aware of yeah the council would need to
um consider that
um and it says it's going to go to
Weight inevitably it will impact on the
openness so the vehicles have been
mentioned it would of course they're um
um temporary in nature and they're not
um
um and and they're movable you know
they're not developments as well
um
I've I've been on the other side and
attempted to persuade inspectors for
that storage tanks uh being in their
temporary nature and how they're
definitely not impacting openness
um because uh are going to have a very
limited impact on openness it depends
doesn't it I mean for example if you
apply for planning permission for a car
park for 2 000 cars the chances are
there's going to be a lot of cars on it
a lot of the time and therefore that is
effective in terms of the impact on on
openness but certainly I accept that
that cars are not the same as buildings
um and the degree of permanence is
weapons there
that that if there's likely to be cars
parked around the house the number of
cars the nature of cars the size of the
vehicles and so on and how long we're
going to be there is going to vary and
it's going to be different from a a
large building I appreciate that it's
but it's a factor again that I can take
into account that there's likely to be
Vehicles yeah and if there's hard
standing there then perhaps it's more
likely that there will be Vehicles there
but as I said I don't know whether the
council will take action in relation to
um the hard standing or whether they're
only basis any basis upon which that
could be what you do have of course the
photographs
so the photographic record yeah so going
back in date so you can see on the
photographs 18 2016.
early in that 2015 or 2016 2016. so
we're six years on from that um what
he's telling is the difference between
2020 and 2022.
127
um
foreign
[Music]
oh and it's a matter obviously matter
for you there's a that looks like
there's a there's a nib uh off to the
in the in the 2022 photograph yes 8.29
the hard standing appears to extend on
the Eastern end it extends further to
the South that's the better as I said
nib isn't it just on that
they're obviously different scales uh
say or they collect different
um
degrees of magnification the bit the the
two cars are on on the 2020 are that's
where the
that's where the building is and then
it's that section immediately to the
right of that isn't it there's a little
bit there's an extension that's what I
was referring to was in need
obviously a matter
just on that um matter of the hard
standing of course if the house can't
fit its discretion but if it were to
take enforcement action before your
decision is
uh a release that that they wouldn't
become a mature consideration well it
yeah say they would necessarily be
the end of the matter there might be an
appeal against it yeah
you asked about intention and I'll pass
it to somebody else
right I mean I should I on reflection I
should have thought a bit more about the
um the fact that the extent of the
outstanding wasn't identified on the
plan in any event and then I just
planning an event but I was as I said I
was working I was on a working laboring
under a misapprehension anyway
right okay that was interesting
debate was different to what I was
expecting on the hard standing but there
we go
and we've really covered the removal of
the fouled drainage in Berry tanks as
well
um there was no well the removal of
materials following so we're on on 11
now the remove the materials following
demolition
um but Mr Telephone I I've obviously
heard what's been said about
the you know
the value of the materials and the
intention of the appellant to to do
something else with them
um but you know
time time would tell as far as that's
concerned but wouldn't refer to say that
there'd be a lot of materials
um
well that's that's the question really
there'd be a lot of materials left after
the demolition of these buildings
there is a lot of material that's why
it's obviously got a value that it has
um uh but uh
there's a question about the storm well
that's that's the point he said there's
a lot of materials there's also been an
indication that well what what would
happen then is an application for
uh certificate of lawfulness
which could have resulted in another
appeal
it could be a long time before these
materials are used in any
any or all of them are used in any
alternative
um permitted Development building in the
meantime they're all on this site and
um effectively that's a storage use is
it not
because if there's a lot of I mean
that's that I'm talking very basic terms
there but it's a question of whether
there's a material change of use but
yeah so no I don't think there is and
it's storage of
wood and that's that's the bit that's
that's the bit that's the expensive part
of this it's Timbers and you know that
obviously needs to be kept um it's
difficult to move uh it needs to be kept
in uh dry and so on but it's got no why
do you say it's difficult to move heavy
as in it it's a specialist job to take
this down they when you see it the size
of it it's going to be taken down if I
uphold the notice
yes so it needs to be done about that
that's why it needs to be done by a
specialist it's not something you know
some
that's a different issue that's that's
moving on to ground G word surely isn't
it yes no no no no no so in terms of
storage it's about into you know that
this can't be
um the reason for saying in terms of
heaviness if you were if the suggestion
was going to be this was easy to move
off site that's the point right so
storage wise
um I don't think it is a material change
of use and it is you know they are
building materials which are related to
the uh residential
um property
and uh therefore I don't think they're I
don't think you run into a difficulty
well as I said if for example you've got
planning permission for the construction
of these other buildings and there were
buildings on site then I don't suppose
the local planning Authority would be
taking enforcement actually against
storage use they're making a point where
they did but uh but we're a couple at
least one stage removed from that in
that you you're saying you'd apply for
the advice to the parent would be to
apply for a certificate of lawfulness I
don't know where that would get refused
or not because it depends on where
you're proposing to do these things and
this whole argument about curses and all
the rest of it if it is refused there
could be an appeal so as I said the
materials could be there for a long time
and you couldn't say at that point until
those proceedings were resolved that
they were there in order to construct a
building for which you'd got permission
or which was going to be lawful
yes but I mean the council if it was
going to enforce I don't know if that's
where this is going uh I mean they've
got the devil's own Job showing that's
Expedia and to enforce in those
circumstances you know I shouldn't
preempt I can't preempt that
subjective of the satellite proceeds I
mean if there are if there is a
Clockwork which is going to be
determined and there's an appeal and the
council thought that it was right to
take enforcement action against storage
of those building materials I'd say best
of luck to them
well
back on
um storing uh stuff in the Greenville
for extended periods of time in a
sensitive value landscape there's some
is not usual
so we didn't come to Studio development
store in domestic terms on the site
there's no change of use of the land
it's not commercial well it doesn't have
to be commercial like and there might be
a section two on five minutes or so yeah
it doesn't to be storage it doesn't have
to be commercial
but it is completely commensurate with
the residential the size of the
residential unit having building
materials on site which the entire for
the intention of putting up uh domestic
related buildings it's not changing
music
anyway it's a question which I'm I
cannot determine in the course of this
appeal but
um it's just part of that
yes
issue whether it's whether it's
necessary
whether the requirements exceed what is
necessary to remedy the breach and
restore the land to its condition prior
to the
prior to the breach
that's that's the purpose we will just
talk about remitting the a breach but
the breach the the provision in the ACT
talks about
um remedying the breach and restoring
the land to its conditioned prior to the
breach
yes but this I mean unless
the stories might be on the land next
door so that wouldn't stop the land from
being restored the land next door but as
in
restoration of the site you take away
the building that's what that's fine
that that happens I think what you're
talking about is storage of the building
materials that doesn't there's no
conflict there
I don't think that's I don't think
that's a question which goes to
Restoration of the land having storage
in the building material
then why is it normal practice to
require all the materials to be removed
it it depends
here the evidence is you've got um
there's all sorts of sustainability
obviously you've got expensive which you
are proposing to you know to use and I I
know so but that's a different point if
you're saying that it's not necessary to
remove the materials to restore the land
to its conditioned price of the breach
then that requirement is always
inappropriate
but it's always in there but you've got
buildings which you break down where you
don't reuse the materials
because you're here I know but that's
that's a different you're saying that's
the reason why they should stay my
question is about what is necessary to
remedy the breach and you were
suggesting that if the material if the
building was taken down and the
materials are put next door
um on a different piece of land to where
the building was then that doesn't
prevent the
land being restored to its condition
prior to the breach but as I say that
suggests that that requirement is always
inappropriate in notices but it's always
there I'm not saying that but I'm saying
that in this case with these materials
there's plenty nothing exceptional about
this case if a notice might be to remove
a house and you might stall the bricks
they're they're building materials you'd
never have that
on that would never be allowed in any
enforcement appeal
um
it's it it's it's entirely reasonable to
require the land to be restored to its
previous condition and that's in the act
and that's in every enforcement pill
that anyone's ever seen and there's
nothing exceptional about this case to
take it outside of that
foreign
okay thank you
um I think we've touched on this but but
um the opponent also says that it's um
the area was not grass before
so is that that's again maybe look at
the photographic evidence I think you've
already referred to it but
it depends on how far back you go
doesn't it
and again bearing in mind that
presumably you're just talking about the
area where the buildings are correct
so
so should that just to avoid any
confusion should that should say reseed
the ground within the footprint of the
buildings
exploring the land back transform the
condition then yes I think that's
probably more appropriate
any views on that from their parents
it's not immediately before the building
and The Works were commenced to kind of
struck the building
so it's immediately before
I'd like to hear what you're going to
say next
I'm just looking at the end I'm just
looking at the photographs
you look at 2020
building is and if you look at Ground
photographs it was a
partly hardcore partly lumpy
um but there was a lot of material in
that corner and if you look at the March
2022 photograph the wiggly bit of
material south of the building
his spoil that was taken out
um from where the building is
um I don't think they'll ask you to put
that back
sorry I don't think they're asking you
to put the spoil back where it was well
I'm just wondering but it was uh that
because I'm asking for it to be grass
and seeded as well
um I don't think that area if I remember
rightly was grass and seeded before the
building was uh put up
um uh it's it's a ghost reading
what condition was it before they before
the building was put up we nothing
specifying that
so I think we're looking forward to
seeing your reference to the weekly bit
in your life
it's for the appellant to understand how
best to restore the land in that case
you see again that's another
although
it always feels a bit unsatisfactory the
it's common and it's held been held to
be adequate for a notice to say we saw
the land to its condition prior to the
breach without actually specifying what
that condition actually is
um you've just said it's for the
appellant
to know effectively what the condition
was so in that case should the notice
refer to receding with grass or should
it simply say restore the land to its
condition prior to the breach and then
you would the local Authority would be
faced with making a view taking a view
on whether they've actually done that or
not
but that's what notices I mean I'm not
saying they never say received with
grass but what I'm saying is it's been
held to be
um sufficient to say that
restore the language conditions prior to
the breach
foreign
to stick with what we've uh suggested it
just seems cleaner and much easier
much more straightforward it does seem
straightforward but but you've been
answered to what Mr Telford said are you
able to say what what the condition was
prior to the brief if you can't say that
it would see that it was covered with
grass then maybe it's not appropriate to
require that
yeah I mean I looking at the aerial
photos it would at least indicate that
part of that field is drastic yeah quite
difficult to specify
yeah and obviously with heart depending
on the nature of the hard standing often
there is hard standing with grass going
through it in an aerial photographs it's
very hard to tell
so can I take an exceptional thought
once again as I've done all the way
through this the statements are common
ground this is not a field
um you know the install it keeps
referring to it as a field uh it's it's
part of Wellness I'm not going to get it
the requirements I've got to be clear
size and this is say that they can say
restore the land to its continuing the
price of the breach and that's
sufficiently clear and precise according
to the course
um but as I said the key question is can
you say that it's conditioned prior to
the breach was grass
if you can't then the nurses shouldn't
really say that so it just it can be on
the balance of probabilities it doesn't
have to be certain oh no I realize that
I'm looking at the area of photographs
it looks like grass
I think it's just Holly's Point okay
is
I mean as far as
yeah I mean we're the building itself is
even when you compare it with the image
of figure 16
um
it appears to be predominantly grass
under the footprint of that building
is that fair
in that very that very far north eastern
corner
yeah where the building is it wasn't
flat it was months and bumps of all
kinds of soil and material and goodness
knows what else and I think there's a
photograph in there quite funny at the
moment it shows it was where material
had been uh partly clipped uh over a
number of years uh apparently we're
building material uh had been moved uh I
think I remember when there was a run at
one time going past the garage uh up
onto the
um
elevated parking area and then you went
down the other side uh that lump was
taken out and a lot of that material was
pushed to the far end so it might have
been
um grass from an aerial photograph which
obviously two dimensionally everything
looks flat
um but in reality uh I'm sure if I
recall nicely it wasn't like that at all
okay well we've had a wiggly bits but
the notice could require a restaurant
you know reseed and reinstall lumps and
bumps
very technical here yeah okay
right
um
now as I said I'm just deleted I forgot
to give you the opportunity to comment
on the the introduction of ground ground
G was there anything you wanted to say
about that
please do something
um
foreign
so talking uh to the owner yesterday
it's a specialist job it's a specialist
outfit you've also got obviously winter
and conditions so
um you know I'm not trying it on but I
think the suggestion was sort of six
months uh and it might be six months
plus three to actually do the work I
don't have the problem with the the
actual
he hasn't contact he hasn't got a
contract in place to remove it but it's
a specialist job given winter
instructions were
um that you were looking at six to nine
so that would take us through to where
we're now December
to some Journey
props an appropriate point for me we're
we're not really supposed to say when
our decisions will be issued
um obviously the time doesn't start to
run until I issue my decision and that's
assuming you don't win
but
um I shouldn't say assuming you don't
win if you don't
um the
I I always used to be able to say I you
know my my decisions I write my
decisions quickly Etc and I can't
promise anything but it's not likely to
be very long
um my situation has changed a bit in
terms of the nature of my job in that
I'm sort of 50
doing my own inquiries it's 150 sort of
line managing people set up it's taking
me longer to make decisions I've got
many more things to juggle so all I can
say is I will write it as quickly as
possible but if I get to this point of
considering
how long it's going to take I'll be
bearing in mind what point we're at as
far as the date of issue of this
decision is concerned and the impact of
winter and all the rest of it
is
amazing
I'm not I'm going to stay in passive
ly
uh the the other problem I have is that
when things like this happen this case
was adjourned it just gets slotted in to
a point in my program where I haven't
been allocated time for actually writing
the decision so I still got I have that
juggling exercise and of course as
Christmas as well so I'm not expecting
you to start being terribly sympathetic
towards me but I'm just saying I'm not
as quick as I used to be for these
various reasons
I like to get decisions off my desk as
quickly as as possible but um
things are stacking up against me a
little bit right so that
takes me to takes us rather to the
consideration of conditions but if you
don't mind I'd like a brief break before
we before we discuss that southern
Journey until just ten to four if that's
okay
setting out the suggested conditions are
set down at 8.2 to 4
of Mr Paulie's rebuttal
roof
the first two relates to
Landscaping
I have something to say about it but was
there anything that you
want to say
foreign
not sure your microphones aren't options
yeah the two conditions that we touched
on earlier and indicating that they will
be acceptable if
the decision was favorable uh the
um Landscaping conditions certainly is
something that would welcome and the
client was already or the fella was
already doing going to do that anyway
right what I want to say about it was
that um it's the usual problem we have
with
retrospective cases in that you have to
ensure
the condition has has teeth because
um
the question Rises well what not so much
what happens if a scheme isn't submitted
because you could you could um you
should Bridge condition notice but if
the scheme is submitted and not approved
nothing else happens
so we end up with this
somewhat convoluted standard form of
condition which the planning inspector
opposes which says
um on on the failure to achieve any of
the following things
the development will be removed
so it looks it looks very harsh but it's
the only way of or you could say
yeah I think that's the only thing you
can say sometimes you could you can
equate you can link it to use but so you
have this stage where you've got to
submit
a scheme if the scheme is approved
you've got to implement it and the
scheme should include a timetable for
implementation as well really
and if it's not approved then you appeal
within a certain period of time
and
um
if the appeal fails then you have to
remove the development zone so it's
very cumbersome about that we've looked
at ways of trying to make it less
look more appealing than it does but
that's the only way we can really ensure
that the condition has any kind of teeth
yes absolutely
I think the uh the three months for
submitting a scheme uh is
um is very generous when it's the same
time as it is to take the building down
um so uh if they wanted it any quicker I
don't look at gifts
but it does have a it has a knock-on
effect on all the other times it goes if
you've got a long time scale for that
then everything else gets gets okay gets
put back so
um so you what you're saying is you you
wouldn't object if it was just say two
months
no
that's not the most important point if
you want to make it a couple of months
that's fine it is absolutely in a
different category to taking down this
building
I think it's it's largely irrelevant
whether it's two or three months because
the trigger is
carried out in the first available
planting team
I mean that may well be sometime after
it's approved
and that's the inspector's condition is
more appropriate in which case would you
know welcome the scheme signal
I think um as I said I think the the
normal way of dealing with this is to
say that the scheme shall include a
timetable for implementation
that's likely to be the first available
planting
season
now you've said
um Mr horley that the reason set out in
the section 13.2
um
commission can't be wrong it's for the
unfinished Building Council cannot
therefore suggest a condition requiring
the building to be retained or completed
in the course of the facility
and we've had the debate about
about all that
okay
um
right and
removal of computer development once
again your
have obviously something that we should
only do in you know
it's not the normal thing to do but
there are reasons for it in this
particular case in regards to the
location
yeah can I can I suggest that they uh is
the word or the words any dwelling house
uh be changed uh because that covers
editing what that covers I think uh it
doesn't say what any dwelling house is
it could compare is it
um I'm just wondering why it's worded as
any dwelling house it was Loosely worded
because we were still dealing with the
ground
and the possibility that there were two
multiple dwelling houses there
foreign
foreign
suggest that there is also a condition
limiting the use of the unfinished
building to incidental purposes only
well scenery I mean I I could hear some
of what you're you're whispering and
um
obviously if they're if if it was no
longer
if there was a material change of use
then planning commissions required so
you don't need to condition to be saying
you can't do something which you haven't
got planning permission so I avoid
conditions like that unnecessarily I
mean often is quite difficult with
Granny annexes and things it's quite
standard so it should be answering is it
really necessary to say that it's become
standard practice too so I don't think
in this circumstance when you've got
buildings which um
I've expressed to be for incidental
purposes and if they were no longer for
incidental purposes
um the chances are they would need
planning permission anyway so
I'm just thinking aloud take us back to
this coverage point we'll have to throw
outside the cartilage
well I think if planning permission is
granted for them as
incidental the thing is the cursive is a
Movable Feast isn't it the customers can
change yes yes it did you can but so I
think it would need to be clear that
we're not going to end up
with a nice new house and a nice new
garage do you still need planning
permission even if it was a different
even if it wasn't in the cursive it
should still be a change of use
if it became a dwelling yeah
if it was ancillary though and still
within the planning unit then it
wouldn't be planning permissions change
of views you can convert a incidental
note building to an ancillary by putting
you know day-to-day living accommodation
as an extension of the house
so what I'm just speaking about is a
merit in a condition which which
prevents that from happening
imagine if you've got an ancillary
outbuilding of that size with all the
day-to-day you know living equipment of
the house has is it then more
straightforward to apply for permission
to convert that so this this owner's
quite happy with his golf it sounds it
is indoor clay pigeon shooting
um
but somebody else may think well there's
a nice garage there and a nice something
that looks a bit like a house
and
well
um
if it's used as a separate dwelling it
would need plenty commission if it's
used as
um and sort of a if it's I mean there's
a whole debate about what what because
these words ancillary incidental get
used all the time with that often
without people really knowing exactly
absolutely we've all I mustn't mentioned
the training manual but the the
um
inspector and distinguish between the
meaning of The Words which the chords
don't really and actually the the pins I
I think it's helpful good because I'm
mainly responsible for that really
and not all inspectors think it's
helpful
but um the um
so I think I think that is anyway that
was just something which
which you could have any further further
conditions so which I mean
I think I think the the difficulty with
ancillary is that often what we people
are talking about is something which is
simply part of
the primary use of the land so for
example if you've got an out building
and you put a a bed in it and so on and
it's used as additional sleeping
accommodation then it's just all part of
the overall use of the planning unit as
a you know as a dwelling house and
residential purposes so there's no
there's no change of abuse and you might
call that ancillary
accommodation doesn't really matter what
you call it there's no there's no change
of change of use incidentally is
different because if it's primary living
accommodation is not incidental
um and obviously that's relevant in
terms of section 55 to our uh in terms
of um committee development rights but
to say that it should only be used
because you you couldn't say that it
should only be used for ancillary
purposes because it's not useful as
planned it's used for incidental
purposes not ancillary
um
but so what you really mean is it
shouldn't be you I mean if you're trying
to say it shouldn't be used as
additional sleeping accommodation again
is that reasonable to do that
you know what what the impacts the main
impacts would come if it was became a
separate dwelling and you would need
planning permission for that if you used
it for guests to stay in is that
necessarily any worse than the use that
it's designed for anyway you know it
doesn't really make that much
most different so I think and I'd need
to be persuaded that there was a real
need
for such a such a condition
I shouldn't have told you about my
involvement
all the bits in it that you like I've
written it's
they do
but as it's not as I say there are
debates certainly within the planning
Spectra
um only last week the debate resurfaced
uh again but um uh the the sort of
stopping here but the conclusion I've
I've come to really is that anyway we as
inspectors we should you where where the
word is used in the legislation or in
the in the um regulations stick with
that word so if it says incidental don't
start talking about ancillary
and beyond that just be careful about
whether it's it's what we're simply
talking about is something which is part
of the parcel of the the permitted the
the lawful use or or not
but you know like as a super granny and
extended granny and its condition uses
the word ancillary
the the gpdo uses the word ancillary uh
when you're talking about putting extra
stories on top of a
a dwelling it talks about it should only
be used for as ancillary purposes but
it's not defined
this is the problem the words aren't
defined anywhere really
well thank you but I don't always feel
clear
you're making me change your mind when
you see my zoom right
sorry about rambling on there but um
is there anything else we need to cover
before
arranging the site site visit
Okay so
what I was thinking
is
um maybe site visit around 9 30.
oh well that doesn't sound like a
favorable response
no I went from Leeds I'll say uh okay so
if it was 10 o'clock would help me
that's fine with me
okay
at the site is that they you see you're
sensible to do that there is I'm told uh
the gate will be open there is no I
don't think there is a
not sure but it's always open it's all
right it's open to drive in there's
parking in front of the house there's a
there's paviors down there's plenty of
space for three because there isn't
really anywhere else to conveniently
Park other than no on the seat because
it is at one be three cars will it one
from the account
foreign
uh yeah
yeah and I'm not being asked to go up
the foot path of time because it's
agreed that I can't really see anything
from there anyway so yeah Johnny gate
Lane's circus all right okay yes well
thanks for reminding me about that uh I
thought too much I mean one thing I have
done is I didn't quite before is to do
closing submissions from them
a site around the table but the client's
not there is it so we're not that's
something we're terribly
um
yeah well and the other thing is we've
been uh of course we've got this yeah
Okay so
site visit at 10 o'clock now I think
um
I will probably have having seen
everything around the area but we've got
to go to Johnny Gate Lane I've thought
about that
um
so
if we allow what you could do uh just to
suggest if you do that on an on a
company basis beforehand Revenge just
just a bit in the property basis I have
to get up early and everybody
I mean 15 minutes or go my second glass
of clarity of breakfast and get there
beforehand and go and have a look at 28
late okay
um yeah so
I mean probably half an hour might be
enough on the site but um
and then call it another half an hour to
get back if I say that we we um resume
here not before 11 o'clock
if we're a bit late then don't start
without us with the leader but um
all right
okay
and I I still haven't got out of the
habit of turning up to the site visits
on Rural sites and Industrial sites
people looking at me thinking
anyway so as I say start site visit 10
o'clock and resume here not before 11
o'clock on our visit I'll look at Johnny
Gate Lane unaccompanied
it depends on the weather but if it's um
I haven't seen the forecast but if it's
in Clement then I might be not wearing a
suit for the bit that's here is that
disgraceful is that acceptable to you
validate the proceedings yeah pins no
longer has a dress code actually but
we're not really sure what that means
for us in practice you know I haven't
seen people pushing the limits but
things have changed haven't I remember
the day you know people used to turn up
on site visits and short strike seats
and all the rest of it and now it is
just jeans and well I don't it wasn't
that long ago that inspectors generally
wore bowler hats yeah yeah you're quite
happy with that experience
well it's in the in the 80s it was only
in the 80s
oh yeah
I know well a friend of mine a colleague
who retired recently his father was a
planning inspector and it was normal for
the council to send the the mayoral
Rolls-Royce to pick him up from the
station you know
yeah I mean you know I think it's
something that should be reinstated
[Laughter]
right okay I'll adjourn until tomorrow
thank you very much